[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
[Music]
okay so today's uh uh outcome of the
podcast is to help you become a better
investor and hopefully become wealthier
because the guests that we have today is
super qualified to do that uh uh it's a
guess I've been looking forward to for a
while uh he he he ran he runs Carlisle
group he is a billionaire I was telling
him earlier if I read your entire bio
it's going to take me five minutes to
read through it they manage Carlisle now
manages roughly 400 billion dollars from
29 States across five different
continents he's the chairman of the
board of the John F Kennedy Center for
the Performing Arts the Council on
Foreign Relations the National Gallery
of Art he sat as the chairman of the
board for Duke University Smithsonian I
mean I can keep going on and on and on I
told them uh prior to getting started is
he's one of the best interviewers I know
when you listen to him interview folks
like Bill Gates Larry Fink Schwartzman I
want to say one of them is Bezos Bill
Clinton President Clinton and president
Bush I can go on and on and on with the
amount of people that you've interviewed
you have a very unique uh funny creative
you know you have a sense to humor style
of interviewing and you push back in a
very unique way and you you know let
them do their part but it's an honor to
have you on the podcast today well I'm
honored to be here thank you for having
me yes and and I had a chance to read
your book how to invest I thought it was
great obviously it's thank you a lot of
the interviews they did but I told I
just came out with a video yesterday top
five books you should read during the
holiday season one of them was how to
invest you're going to get to heaven for
saying that
thank God because of all the other
reasons why I wouldn't be able to go but
it's good to have you on we've got a lot
of topics I want to go through obviously
some of it is uh uh your success story
how you became who you became because
that's inspirational for a lot of people
to learn about but then also we got
topics with today's economy inflation uh
you know whether it's FTX I forgot to
even say you interviewed Sam bankman
freed a few months ago three months ago
it's very interesting him telling you I
got three 11 text messages on my phone
half of them would be people asking me
for money just very casually he says
that to you in the interview but we got
a lot of things to talk about I was with
the David Solomon two weeks ago in Miami
at dinner and we talked about
unemployment I think the way you're
explaining unemployment is slightly
different than the way they see it and
then I talked to my guys from Morgan
Stanley Dean with her they have a
different position Bloomberg has a
different position B of A has a
different position it'd be interesting
to see what you think is going to be
happening ESG and some other topics
we'll get into as well but you know I
know your story but some of the audience
may not know your story prior to you
becoming who you are today tell us a
little bit about how you came about
becoming who you are today
um I'm uh an only child born in
Baltimore my parents did not graduate
from college or High School my father
worked in the post established made
maybe ten thousand dollars a year when
they retired he retired at the age of 55
and moved to a suburb of Baltimore
called West Palm Beach Florida and uh
you know I grew up going to you know
Public Schools I did get a scholarship
to go to Duke University and I got a
scholarship to go to the University of
Chicago
I did serve as chairman of the board of
University of Duke University for a
while and now I'm chair of the
University Chicago Board and I have uh I
got very lucky in my business career I
started Carlisle when I was 37 it became
one of the larger private Equity firms
in the world and now I uh committed to
giving away all my money I was an
original center of the giving pledge and
I've made large gifts to lots of
different places around the country and
I have three children they are all mbas
they're all in private Equity pursuing
what I call Mankind's highest calling
and uh they're doing okay and so I think
they're on they're safely launched and
they don't need me to give them billions
of dollars to be successful David who
are you in high school if we're in 10th
Grade who were you in high school I was
a nerdy little kid uh if you asked my
high school class who would be the most
successful person in class most people
wouldn't know I was in the class I was a
large public high school 1 500 people in
my class in your class my class so I was
big we had one guidance counselor for 1
500 people
um it was uh I would say uh you know a
big public high school Melting Pot
public high school but I was I skipped a
year of junior high school so I was only
you know 16 when I graduated high school
I was only 14 when I entered it so I was
you know probably young my voice
probably hadn't changed very much and
and um you know I was not a great
athlete I wasn't a great scholar I
wasn't a great anything so uh the same
was true in law school and and in
college I wasn't great at anything I got
lucky later in life you know I've
determined in in parts of life you
divide life into thirds the first third
you often find the people are the
superstars the Rhodes Scholars the
Supreme Court clerks the people that are
the student body presence sometimes they
make it later on in life but mostly they
don't and then the people in the second
third and third third they're the ones
who kept working hard like the tortoise
versus the hair and they kind of passed
everybody else so think about your high
school class who was a superstar in that
class the person you said might be
president United States he or she may
not be that famous now all the people
who became presidents of the United
States in the last 100 years only one of
them was probably seen as a good student
or a star at that time that was probably
Bill Clinton he was a pretty good
student that was a later became a Rhodes
scholar most of the people who become
president United States are not people
that were that famous or that well known
our current president very nice person I
know him quite well but you know he was
a you know a football player in high
school not considered to be likely
president United States his predecessor
Donald Trump probably wasn't thought to
be potential president United States
when he was younger and so on so it's
just the life life evolves that way and
you can't tell who's going to be coming
the next president United States just by
looking at their resumes when they were
in high school
um you know I don't know your background
that well but were you a superstar in
high school now you're very well known
Russian it had a 1.8 GPA literally I had
a one point I failed biology and I was
good in math that was it all right so
now you're very well known you're
prominent so forth
um in your high school class who would
have predicted that you would become
this successful zero right I went to the
Army right after high school well look I
didn't go in the army I my father was an
Marines I didn't go when I was too
skinny I didn't think I'd pass the uh
the physical
nice father was a devil dog wait were
you a superstar in high school I was not
a 2.2 GPA so go over your commonality
1.8 2.2 GPA no college degree
you guys are 4.0 between the two of you
correct I love your Edition all right
Marine Corps math there you go so so
David so you have three kids but you
were the only child so and then your
kids went to private Equity but your dad
was in the you know Postal Service and
your mom was a homemaker so what was the
advantages of being a single child was
was a disadvantages to make you want to
have three kids because you didn't have
only one kid when you were an only child
at times you might say what it's like
wouldn't it be great to have a sibling
but most of my friends who have siblings
were fighting with them all the time and
now I notice that most of my friends who
have siblings probably don't spend that
much time with them as adults so um
there's pluses and minus like everything
in life I don't regret it um if you look
back and regret things that happen in
your life you'll be very miserable the
hardest thing in life to do is to be
happy that's the most elusive thing in
life achieving personal happiness and
I'm pretty happy I got lucky in life and
I'm reasonably happy with where I am now
I wish I was younger looking I wish I
didn't have all this gray hair I wish I
could lose more weight I wish I was in
Greater shape but generally I'm
reasonably happy and if you're Jewish
that's hard to do
um so I'm reasonably happy
um
um but you know I I recognize that
happiness is difficult to achieve and
many people in life go through life not
being very happy they're sad that
they're not wealthier handsomer or
whatever it is and they never Achieve
Personal happiness you have to accept
where you are and try to make the best
of it within reason you can obviously
try to do better but you know and having
children you have children I assume I do
four of them okay so that's I have three
uh your children are much younger
obviously the 10 9 6 and 17 months okay
so you're young children right now
they're not fully formed as you can't
tell whether they're going to be
superstar athletes or whatever and right
now you have them under your control
more or less when they get to be
teenagers a little more challenging when
they're young adults you know they make
call you back they may not call you back
so raising children is the most
difficult thing to do in life
interesting wow more than marriage
tougher than marriage
yes because you're dealing with more
than one person typically you're dealing
with three or four different children or
if you have four children and it's very
difficult also marriage is complicated
but but children is the heart hardest
thing to do is raising children who are
happy and successful and that's very
hard to do now
um when you're wealthy and reasonably
prosperous it's even harder because I
had no money growing up and I realized
I'm going to get anywhere I got to work
hard yep if you have money the tendency
is to give your kids money make it easy
for them and in the end you're probably
hurting them so it's not easy to raise
raise kids when you have a lot of money
or your prominent or you're successful
very difficult to do that I think so so
there's a lot of context a lot of
questions right there so one I've heard
a lot of different formulas about
happiness what's yours and two how do
you do it with the kids when you do have
money at what point is it important to
manage expectations with them well with
my children they're well educated they
went to Harvard Stanford and Duke and so
forth so they got a good education but
they um you know they always challenge
every child has challenges no perfect
child so you always have challenges and
a parent has to figure out how to deal
with child health challenges or whatever
they might be I would say
um if I said to my children I'm giving
you each a billion dollars and they got
a billion dollars would they make them a
better person I don't know
um very rarely do you inherit a billion
dollars and all of a sudden you win a
Nobel Peace Prize or something like that
people that change the world often come
from Blue Collar backgrounds or middle
class backgrounds the people that change
the world and the ones you really want
to admire are people that really came
from backgrounds probably like yours and
mine
to give me the formula for happiness
well my formula for happiness is is
basically of course being reasonably
healthy that's good because you don't
want to have health problems but but
basically having a relationship with um
other people that you that you find uh
satisfying particularly your children
secondly
um it's giving back to other people
um generally when people help other
people they feel better about themselves
uh people who don't help anybody else
probably don't feel that well that great
about themselves there are many people
who are very wealthy extremely wealthy
they don't give away very much and I
don't think they're very happy people
um generally giving away money or your
time your time is more valuable than
your money you can make more money you
can't make more time I think people that
do that feel happier about themselves
and as a general rule of thumb I
encourage people to do philanthropic
things which I include meaning giving
your time and your volunteering uh
things not just money
um people that I I isolated that sit in
their house and just count their money
and big build big houses and count how
big their boat is I'm not sure they're
that happy the most tortured Souls I
know are extremely wealthy people the
happiest people I know are often people
have no money now that doesn't mean you
don't want to have any money but you
have to make sure you understand what
money is all about it's designed to make
you I think have a better life but
you're gonna have a better life if you
help other people now I tell people all
the time when I'm making philanthropic
or pitches when you when you're trying
to give away when you give away money
give away time help other people you'll
feel happier about yourself happier
people live longer grumpy people don't
live as long also there's a special
place in heaven reserved for people that
do this now people laugh when I say that
but I say why would you want to take a
chance and I'm wrong I could be right
you don't know you sound like a pastor
saying that that's the pastor's uh close
right so um you know in life as you get
older I'm obviously older than you you
know what you do worry about as you get
older is your health because we all know
uh you know the people don't don't have
the same lifespan when I was younger I
used to ask my parents why do you read
the obituary pages and they say well I
want to see who I knew that died I read
the obituary Pages now because my
friends are dying um you know people
younger than me are dying I'm saying how
come I'm lucky that I'm not dead and my
friends are are gone in some cases so
you know when you read the obituary
pages and you see somebody 45 55 65
dying what are they they do wrong how do
they have such bad fortune so you know
every day is a blessing in a sense that
you know you're trying to do something
useful with your life and hopefully uh
you know you have a long time to go to
make your kids uh you know appreciate
what you've built but in the end raising
four children is not easy yeah I got
some questions for you because I'm
wondering I want to go to the sponsor
but I'm wondering if you think it's
easier to if we lived in a different
country where you can have four wives or
four kids which one would be easier
that's a technical question to ask as a
middle eastern man here secondly I've
only been 44 once and I want to know
what it's like to go into 50s 60s 70s
wealth creation compounding all that
stuff but let me first go to the sponsor
all right you can think about some of
those questions because you said raising
kids is harder than marriage I actually
want to know a little bit more about
that so quick shout out to our sponsor
today funding grow over the last 15
years funding grass cultivated a way to
separate your business finances from
your credit and prevent risk of your
personal assets as collateral throughout
the membership funding grow maintain
change the credit cards at zero percent
interest so that you can effortlessly
manage your day-to-day business expenses
Additionally you won't give up equity in
your business because you will
completely control the funding anyone in
almost any industry can use business
credit from purchasing inventory to
closing on an investment property
unsecured business credit is one of the
most innovative ways to get startup
Capital without having to uh weave
through lots of red tape and Banks and
if you don't have a business yet but you
have an idea they're going to get you
set up with a complimentary LLC or sole
proprietary ship that will save you time
and money having to set it up for
yourself or pay an attorney to do so but
don't take don't take it from me when
you look them up that's the first thing
we notice by the way they have 2400 4.9
stars out of five online reviews from
clients and so if you want to learn a
little bit more about them check out
their special offer for free a webinar
that explains everything about what they
do by their CEO they will explain it to
you there's a link below that Rob if we
can put it in the chat as well as the
description for you guys called learn
more more about fund and grow I think
that's the second time we're doing this
with these guys we looked them up a lot
and we're happy to share their uh what
they do uh for the folks that follow PVD
podcast okay so let's go back into it
you said marriage is easier than kids
okay for me uh uh I'm not gonna make it
clear marriage half the people that get
married are divorced so it obviously
isn't that easy I don't make it sound
like it's easy yeah but but I guess I
guess the question I want to ask from is
the following uh did your wife help you
like did you and your wife build a
business together was or was it always
separate all right okay but I people who
build business with their partner uh and
their smart their spouse I think it's
that can be done but sometimes when
you're working together with somebody 24
hours a day it's a little challenging
because you have you know there's always
tensions and sometimes I've noticed that
husband wife businesses don't work as
well so okay so so for you you've seen
it not work if they're working together
but you've also seen it not work if it's
separate because to me the way I would
see it is and push back in you know say
nah I don't agree with you if your wife
working on this business with the
insurance business we did everything
together she's got office upstairs and
first time we shared an office together
she said babe we can't be in the same
office you're too loud so we put and we
literally had an office complete
opposite ends uh and then I saw a lot of
my friends who made money
and they built the business separately
it's as if the more time was going by
interest was you know separating and
there were no running for the same cause
except for the kids the only thing that
was in common was kids and then
eventually it went from being a wife to
being a roommate that's what I saw a lot
of times with people who were doing two
different businesses now you have more
wisdom and I than I do that's why I'm
asking your gray hair you don't have any
gray hair I have some of it my wife I
was standing there
wow
Jimmy Carter whom I work in the white
house he's been married 75 years
the only time he came close to getting
divorced was when he and his wife agreed
to write a book together they found out
they couldn't they couldn't they
couldn't do it they ultimately gave the
publisher the money back and they didn't
they didn't do it or at least to write
the book together it was uh so that was
the only time he said he ever got close
to getting divorced so you know working
together with a partner and a spouse can
be wonderful at times when things work
out but when there's problems who gets
blamed and who you know it's I don't
want to get into the whether it's easier
to raise children or be um uh marriage
but uh raising children my point is is
very difficult and you've got four
children you're going to be with them
their their father their whole life and
I ask people when do you stop worrying
about your children I think when they
turn 60 or 70 you probably stop worrying
about them but the rest of your life
every time you get a call late at night
you're gonna for my child you're gonna
wonder what went wrong and they're out
later than you wanted to be out what are
they going to do you know when they're
one and two and three years old they
look Angelic when they're 15 and 16 and
17 and they're trying to do something
you don't want to do not so Angelic
David why why do so many billionaires
marriages not end up working out uh I
talked to one of my pastors who says
look I just want to tell you this I
don't know what it is but when you
become a billionaire things change kids
change not kids change relationships
change family looks at you differently
friends look at you differently you have
to be kind of careful on how to maneuver
through those things when you're making
that kind of money is it the fact that
more billionaires are getting divorces
or is it the fact that billionaires are
more known and people know them and we
know this more when they get divorces
than the average person gets it's a
ladder actually there's a higher divorce
rate among people who are blue collar
workers really a harder very interesting
for higher divorce rate wow
um they have more challenges as well but
billionaires when they make a lot of
money how do you make a lot of money
it's not just sitting around you're
tough you're you're you're driven and
when you take those qualities and you
bring it to your marriage it's a little
more challenging you say to your wife
look I'm a brilliant person I made a
billion dollars what did you contribute
today to the marriage and you know that
can tend to you know be offsetting
sometimes there are billionaires that
that uh that you know have reasonably
good marriages my observation but as
we've known some of the wealthiest men
in our country have recently gotten
divorced so it's not that easy to be
married when you're that rich yeah it I
I'm sure listen marriage is already hard
letter on out adding all the other
components to it but uh you know maybe
there's an element and again I don't
know where you go outside where you know
the whole scene where uh everybody says
oh my God it's this look who it is oh my
goodness oh my God can I believe I need
to come home hey babe can you take out
the trash you know I'm saying like do
you know who I am well there is that
element yeah you know for example when
you're you're in the office you're
treated like a god you're everybody
works for you when you come home you're
not a God you got to go pick out you
know take out the garbage or deal with
the kids change the diaper whatever it
might be and people say I don't have to
do this I'm a billionaire I'm a
multi-billionaire but sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't question another
question here before we go into the
topic and then we'll just do a lot of
current events I'm trying to learn as
much from you as possible so the only
age just the first time I've been 44
years old I was kind of telling you this
earlier so you know what's the
difference like for you I can tell the
difference of what happened from the 20s
to 30s to 40s that's what I can talk
speak on like in my teens in the Army
energy going eating pizza you don't
worry about it nothing happens I can eat
two large pizzas in a night next day I
still have my six-pack it doesn't matter
right you know energy in the 20s and
then 30s flexibility 40s you know bones
back what what do you notice but also I
notice with experience of negotiation
leverage you know how to go into
different board rooms how to read
different personalities on the business
end but what was the biggest difference
going from 20s 30s for was there
something that you can point to well
when you're in your 20s you think you're
going to live forever and you just uh
you know you can do anything you want
um but by the time you're in your 40s
your life pattern is largely set in
other words if you're 44 years old
you're probably going to be on a path
towards success or not success generally
entrepreneurs at 55 don't start new
companies and they change their life it
happens but generally not yeah so now I
read the reason I started Carlisle at uh
was I read that entrepreneur will start
his or her company between the ages of
28 and 37 you know obviously they're
Mark zuckerbergs and Bill Gates
exceptions but 28-37 I read that when I
was 37. so I said I better start
something I'll never be an entrepreneur
interesting so you're Now 44 you're on a
path towards a certain level of success
and we continue this path no doubt in
your 50s will be even more successful
had you not started what you're doing
now and you tried to do this when you're
50 it might be harder to get it started
because by then you've got kids or older
you got to deal with you've got more
financial challenges all kinds of other
things now you can get this going but
and you're on a path towards um you know
success when you hit 50. you know that
most likely you've lived more than
you're going to live and you have to
look at things a little bit differently
when you're 44 you can say well maybe
I'll make it to 88 so maybe I'm only
halfway through
um but you know people have uh you know
40th birthday parties that's when they
kind of say I'm really moved into
adulthood I'm really a real adult now I
can't pretend I'm a kid anymore yeah so
when you're 44 you know you're a young
on the other hand if you're a
professional athlete at 44 you would be
you know you'd be gone if you're done I
mean how many professional athletes
other than uh Tom Brady Tom Brady are
there playing at any sport at the age of
44 so while you're young looking now if
you're a professional athlete you would
be seen as too old yeah that'd be uh
being asked to being a head coach or
assistant coach or something like
hopefully if that's what you want to do
what to expect in 50s 60s 70s
well as you get older and you're
successful people will will uh I treat
you more with more respect presumably if
your success continues also you have
more of a responsibility to give back
you're going to Mentor people more and
more and ultimately you got to figure
out what you're going to do with your
wealth
um you can build a pyramid to how great
you are you can buy yachts and so forth
or you can give some of it away and you
have to figure out how do you want to
use that wealth in an intelligent way
and be a good role model for your
children
uh any any blind spots to look out for
any blind spots so be careful with this
be careful with that be careful with
this hubris you know when people tell
you how great you are you got to be
discounting that because very few people
are that great I mean there are very few
real geniuses that are floating out
there or people that really change the
world so you know I mean you know Darwin
may have changed the world Einstein
changed the world but we shouldn't think
that we're going to be Darwin or
Einstein just because we made a lot of
money got it hubris I just read this
book by Jim Collins what's uh how the
mighty not a mighty fault and what was
the first step was it was number one
number one hubris is what causes people
to uh to fall so compounding the the
other thing I want to talk about is
compounding you know when you're you're
really working hard you're doing your
part like oh my God I'm so good like fun
putting so much effort on the front oh
first time I've ever made a hundred
thousand dollars six figure oh my God
like this is amazing will I ever make a
million
grinding you make a meal but that's
amazing I'm making a million bucks I'm
gonna top you know half a percent of
America this is sick but I don't know if
I'll ever get to 10. you know will my
business ever get there we got to 10
million dude but there's no way I'm
going to get to the heck the side when
did you know like listen
the likelihood of me being a billionaire
in the next 13 years is very high your
math guys so far you've done a bunch of
different things that's math I said 1.8
2.2 you said combined we had 4.4 4.0 you
said 44 years old 88 50 you're not
thinking so everything in your mind and
I know you're a math guy yourself as
well but at what point did you say I
think I'm gonna be this within because
you're numbers guys so I know the
typical the humbles I never thought
about being a billionaire that was never
part of the goal I totally get that I
understand that's not part of the goal
but it is a milestone when did you say
at this point if I go at this rate we're
probably going to reach that number
probably when I was maybe 15 years in a
starting car I started when I was 37 so
probably when I was early 50s I said
okay this is going to be one of the
larger private Equity firms in the world
and as an owner of it I'll probably do
well but and I didn't obsess over it and
you know when Forbes puts out these
lists then people pay attention to you
so my children didn't really know the
level of my wealth until Forbes comes
out and publishes a thing and that's
true with your neighbors my neighbors
I'm going to this I'm living the same
house now for 35 years or so and people
they don't really know what I do that
much and maybe a little bit but you know
one day they might read the Forbes and
say hey this guy is worth X billions of
dollars and he's living on taking out
his garbage less like us so uh you know
it but in the end it's like anything in
life when you pass it through you go
into the next thing if you obsess over
being it now there are a couple people
who obsess over being on that list
um you know I won't mention them but
there are people who have sued Forbes
for not being on the list uh or not
being high enough on the list but if you
obsess over your numbers you know it's a
mistake you can't confuse your net worth
with your self-worth if you basically
just say I'm worth X dollars and
therefore I'm really great that's a
mistake don't worry about your net worth
worry about what you're really doing
with your life that's much more
important very interesting and yeah I've
heard the stories about people soon
Forbes for either being too low or too
high you know not on the list not right
no not on the list but uh interesting
let me see if I had any other thing here
no aside from this I think we can get
into a current event so you said
Geniuses uh you mentioned Darwin and you
mentioned Einstein who would you say is
a genius today like if you were to give
a couple names who would you put in that
genius level today
well people that are well known I would
say uh I'd say uh Elon Musk is a very
smart person I've interviewed him
um you know he obviously like all really
brilliant people has eccentricities
nobody I mean Einstein was eccentric um
he didn't wear socks ever he was he
couldn't comb his hair ever they got
lost walk into home he you know
brilliant people often are eccentric in
some ways now some people say that
everybody's eccentric it's just the
brilliant people and the famous people
the ones that get away with it but I
think Elon Musk is a really really smart
person
um I think Bill Gates is very very smart
uh Mark Zuckerberg very very smart but
the word genius is overused how many
real geniuses are there and what does it
really mean to be a genius so there's
some math professors somewhere that are
probably Geniuses but I don't really
know them that well there are very few
people that you would say when they walk
in the room you say this is Albert
Einstein updated very few people like so
you would put musk it seemed like
there's only one name musk is very very
smart and maybe a genius but how do you
measure genius I think Bill Gates what
he did he built a great great company
and he's done great things in
philanthropy is he a genius I don't know
how do you measure genius uh clearly
Mark Zuckerberg I think built a great
company that's obviously had his
challenges lately
um the Google guys have built Google
have really really smart people but what
does it really mean to be a genius I
mean it's hard to know
interesting to say that with Elon Musk
we're going to get into Elon Musk as
well by the way Carlisle your clients
your clients some of them are
Republicans some of them are Democrats
some of them are independent some of
them are you know politically they're
all over the place right you're not
going to just
maybe even more of your clients are
Republican than Democrats possibly I
don't know if they are or not but you
don't do a survey and say so who did you
vote for you can't do that it's not
something that you do but you know where
they lean it's like you know when
they're giving money to one Saturday
like do you know Schwartzman where he
leans you know where you know a uh JP
Morgan leans you know where Larry
finklings you know where a lot of these
guys lean it's not hard to kind of
figure out what these guys lean how do
you uh I run an insurance company we've
licensed new to 40 000 people you know
we have I don't know 15 000 agents
Nationwide few hundred offices
Nationwide we just sold the company to
IMG
who the money came from Silver Lake you
know these companies you know these
names so you know but some of the guys
that you have they're Democrats some of
them are Republican and you know you're
you're spending your Thanksgiving I mean
the president was with you during
Thanksgiving no no let me be honest I
lent him the house I I wasn't there I
wasn't I was in Florida but even that
like I mean to say you know okay Biden
state so if I go like and the only
reason I'm saying this this is actually
a question I'm asking because a lot of
people are uncomfortable about this so
you know where you know you ask Sam
bankman freed and he said yeah I don't
know who I'm going to give the money to
I may get I'm gonna probably give the
money to both people on both both sides
of the aisle I'm going to give to some
Republicans some Democrats you know but
then some of the guys at the top you
notice they're typically on one side who
they're giving money to how do you
manage the relationships where they say
Let me let me describe yeah I'm curious
I worked in the white house for
President Carter
um we lost the election of Ronald Reagan
so an election uh changed my future I
thought I would stay in the White House
another four years I decided to get out
of politics and to do something
different with my life I don't give
money to any politician in zero I'm not
involved never none zero none what's
your philosophy for that I'm curious
well my view is I'd like to be friendly
with people in the Democratic party and
people in the Republican party and I
don't want people to judge me by who I
made a campaign contribution to and also
when you're giving gigantic sums of
people money to people you have to
wonder
um is that a really great thing for
democracy so I I I don't want to
criticize other people do it I I stay
out of that what I try to do is bring
people together in this way
um I host a lunch a dinner for members
of Congress only members of Congress
once a month I try to I bring a great
historian and I will uh interview that
person in front of only members of
Congress I asked the Democrats
Republicans to sip of people from the
opposite party people from the opposite
house doing it for seven years and
people love it and they say it's one of
the most interesting things they're
doing in Congress is going to this
dinner because there's no press there
they can sit and talk with people from
the office of party which they rarely
are allowed to do in today's environment
in Washington DC
um but if I was known as a big Democrat
or a big Republican it'd be harder to do
that I'm chairman of the Kennedy Center
I've been chairman for 13 years if I was
an active Democrat or actually act a
republican I think it'd be harder to do
what I do which is to bring Democrats
and Republicans to the County Center the
same is true with the Smithsonian when I
was chair of the Smithsonian I didn't
want to be seen as an active Democrat or
active Republican some people are but I
just thought it was better for me to be
able to bring people together from both
sides so that's the way I'd look at it
David just out of curiosity because the
fact that you you've never given money
to well I didn't say never I did years
ago many more decades ago but not in
recent 25 years since you since you made
your money let's just say since you
really made the one you haven't given
money up do you think uh if you were in
charge of policies it would be better if
none of us could to find out who's the
real candidate versus you know
constantly going out to campaigning
because a lot of this is now about
campaigning who can raise the most money
can you know there's a general rule of
thumb the person who has the most money
will probably win an election is a
general rule yeah I'm not always and so
clearly uh if this was a different
country we would call it you know uh
legalized bribery you're basically
getting you know if somebody gives you
five million dollars million dollars
what do you think that person wants for
that they want something I don't know
what it'll be and I'm not saying it's
necessarily illegal uh we we've
sanctioned it but somebody's giving 5 10
15 20 million dollars they want
something and you have to wonder well
that's a good thing now unfortunately
members of Congress spend so much of
their time raising money now that they
they they uh they can't spend as much
time as they want on the legislative
matters 40 of the time of house members
is often spent raising money that's a
lot and the reason is the more money you
raise the more likely you're going to
win and the and if you have money left
over you can keep it now more or less
for political purpose for the rest of
your life yeah I'm not I'm not a fan of
that because that's that's uh you you
owe too many favors you know it's kind
of like yeah I owe favor to this guy
today I got today hey remember that one
time I gave you this it's like you know
you're in debt to the people that are
giving you money I don't know if it
makes the relationship more straight up
but David to be honest I mean look I
don't have a better system um I don't
know what better government we we could
have and as Churchill said uh democracy
is the worst form of government except
all the others so I our government has
lots of challenges our political system
has lots of challenges but I'm not
seeing people leaving this country to go
to another political system we have 50
million people in this country who are
immigrants 50 million people many of
them are citizens 50 million how many
people have leaving this country every
year to go elsewhere maybe uh you know
small percentage very very few people
leave yeah because the country's got all
its challenges but still the best
country in the in the world anything
would confuse though why do you think
we're confused where you know I turn on
the TV sometimes as a guy that was born
in Iran lived there 10 years I lived two
years in a refugee camp came to the
states and I hear so many people that
were born you're bitching about America
like how how did Americans not be proud
of being Americans like it became cool
for the last few years to hear people
bitching about the country that gave
them the life that he gave them
well 50 million people wouldn't have
immigrated here if it was such a
terrible place I think um no other
country in the world's even close the
other the only other country even close
in terms of immigrants is Germany about
10 to 15 million people but people
aren't rushing to China people aren't
rushing to go to live in Russia the
Philippines people are pushing to live
here and obviously now people are coming
across the border illegally and that's
because they're so interested in coming
this country it's not because people
aren't leaving this country to rush to
Mexico right right that's right well
it's good to hear by the way how do you
think the president's doing I know
you've commented on Trump on his
policies economy in the past before how
do you think President Biden's doing
specifically economic policies well
obviously inflation got out of control
it wasn't transitory I think the Federal
Reserve Jay pal used to work at our firm
I I've known quite well
um I used to work at Carlo he worked at
Carlisle for seven or eight years
um he's uh done a very good job but the
biggest problem we had is that when
covet came we didn't know what to do
with it so uh the Trump Administration
the body admination five trillion
dollars into the economy which had an
inflationary impact and the Federal
Reserve came interest rates at zero that
had inflationary impact we didn't
realize how serious it was going to be
but now we're playing catch up I think
the inflation is coming down the economy
is in reasonable shape and as the Biden
I think he's done a pretty good job
given the circumstances he inherited
got it uh okay so let's go into let's go
into some topics here let's go into some
topics here first topic is Insider uh
this is just a few days ago paid seven
uh billionaire David Rubinstein says a
recession is coming Tech valuations are
set to fall uh further this is what
December 13th right go to this year page
seven let me read this article too not
the whole thing just the highlights of
it uh
okay I suspect the FED is determined to
not make another mistake on inflation
Rubenstein said I think the FED
generally would say that the myth they
misread how much inflation was going to
be caused by the 5 trillion dollar
inject them to the economy by Congress
to deal with covid which is what you
just said right and also the current
quantitative easing impact as well
inflation was transitory they said but
it turned out it wasn't along with a
recession and the rise of unemployment
Rubenstein says tech company valuations
are expected to fall further on harsh
economic conditions into next year I
think some of the tech companies that
have changed our lives for the better
are very good and maybe their value will
be coming down a bit but I think a lot
of valuations for fewer tech companies
that don't have revenues let alone
earnings probably are going to come down
more than a bit so the question about
recession next year what's the recession
going to be you know the the phrase
everyone's using is it's going to be a
soft we're going to have a soft Landing
we're gonna have a soft Landing what do
you think is going to happen next to the
recession which remind everybody a
recession is to find many different ways
but the shorthand is two consecutive
quarters where the GDP growth rate is
negative
um and there are other factors beyond
that but let's say it's two consecutive
quarters no one really knows whether
we're going to go in a session or not
everybody when we go into recession if
we do we'll come out with their memos
saying see I told you so I have my memo
it's in their files now they'll drag it
out and if they if actually go into
recession it's easy to predict a
recession because if you're predicted
you're not right people aren't probably
going to call you uh six months later
and say you were wrong right now the
Federal Reserve is trying to get the
inflation rate down to two percent I
think that's too low probably three
percent is more realistic but if it can
get it down to three percent on a
consistent basis and we've had three
percent for the last couple months so
that they can consistently get down
three percent I think we could avoid a
recession but the FED uh may be more
worried about inflation than it is about
unemployment and therefore they may
increase interest rates a little bit
more than maybe necessary and as a
result it could go into a recession
probably a temporary or short-term
recession that would be my view not not
nothing like the Great Recession we had
in 2008 2009. um nobody really there's
no magic formula to know whether you can
jack up interest rates a certain amount
and it's going to produce inflation one
of the problems we've had is typically
when you increase interest rates
unemployment goes up as well because
interest rates go up people fire people
things uh to change but it's been a it's
been a very big mystery to the federal
government and how the unemployment rate
is staying so low and that's in part
because we haven't figured out the post
coveted impact of employment for example
historically in this country 66 percent
of all the adult males and females are
in the workforce 66 now it's 62 percent
where those people go well older people
retired after the Great Recession
younger people don't want these
entry-level jobs they're not working
anymore they went back to school and a
lot of people just aren't working they
just figure they don't need to work
anymore they made some money in covet so
when you don't have that many people in
the workforce the result is you've got
to pay higher prices to get people to
work because you need to get filled fill
these places so it's not like you can
lay people off so easily these days it's
just not happening and as a result
unemployment is not going up
so the participation rate is really what
was in there that people don't talk
enough about to understand participation
rate goes down Supply goes down price
goes up very simply right I mean to get
employees if you want to get entry level
employees to work for you how are you
going to get them well you're not going
to get them by minimum wage minimum wage
in this country legally is like seven
and a half dollars an hour now nobody's
paying that because you can't get
anybody's no ways right nobody's paying
720 and I know they're always talking
about raising it's like if anybody paid
720 right now you wouldn't have any
employees right but you said something
two things you said definition of
recession is back to back quarters
negative right so if right if that's the
case were you saying that because you're
trying to say we've you know technically
been in a recession since July 1st is
that kind of what you were alluding to
or no no last year or earlier this year
in the first and second quarters of this
year yeah we had two consecutive
quarters of negative growth it wasn't
caught a recession by anybody because
other things were happening sales growth
were still going on sales and recession
are going down retail sales were going
up exports were going up so it was a
technical recession and the reason was
technical is the reason the supply the
reason GDP went down is we were
basically filling up our supplies from
the covid situation in other words
manufacturers weren't making a lot of
stuff and selling all that stuff because
they had a lot of excess supplies left
over from from the recession from from
the from the coveted period of time so
it wasn't considered a recession but if
we go into a recession in the future two
consecutive quarters almost certainly
will be considered a recession but you
know it a recession is um you know it
defined by Economist different ways uh I
would say if we go into a recession
it'll almost certainly be very brief
because right now we don't have the
problems we had in 2008 and 2009 where
the banks are in financial trouble we
don't have a lot of people in financial
trouble right now I think the biggest
challenge we have is that inflation's
still high now it's coming down because
it you know the most recent numbers show
they're coming down but if the FED feels
it has to increase interest rates
further uh to get inflation down that
could produce a recession we need just
don't know and the FED doesn't know is
Jerome Powell uh like does he have a
board that he calls on like do you guys
you Jamie you know Stephen think is
there like does he can't say hey guys
what do you think about this here's what
we're thinking about because it's it's
it's got to be a very tough place for
him to be if he can't lean on some of
the free market guys to talk to them
well he does talk to them from time to
time they go to see him he has to see
him he's he meets with them from time to
time sure
um but he also has incredibly good
economists who work at the fed and they
have pretty good data and they they kind
of know what the economy is doing but
nobody's perfect in this business and
lots of times um you know you make
mistakes at the fed and the FED has
admitted that it made a mistake on
inflation earlier Janet Yellen said that
they made a mistake
yeah she didn't have we ever been in a
time uh David where uh uh the amount of
things experts are getting wrong right
now has been higher than today and the
reason why I'm saying this the following
reason so for example hey you know if
you keep printing money Gold's gonna go
to five thousand nope hey if you keep
printing money you know the Bitcoin is
going to go to 100 000. nope hey uh guys
if we keep printing money you know we're
going to get the money to go to the port
nope the money went to the poor and poor
spending and the billionaires became
richer and they kind of favored them
because anytime you give the money to
the poor the poor is going to spend the
money and it goes into private economy
they don't save money because they don't
have the habits of saving money hey
anytime we hey this this inflation is
going to be transitory hey recession is
going to be soft Landing like the level
of trust the average consumer today has
an expert saying what they think is
going to happen to the economy I saw a
score the other day it's a very
interesting score I don't know if you've
seen this or not the score was the
correlation between the trust the
American voter has in the government and
the last since since uh 1970 I think it
was how important from 74 we trusted the
US government's like 25 right now and
then the score you put it right next to
trust and mainstream media from where it
was in 1970s to today David you got to
take a look at this it's literally
identical here's one of them this is
what trust and public uh in the
government from 58 till today from 75
all the way down to less than 20 percent
if you do the same thing with mainstream
media it's down as well I would say if
we put it with experts today would be
the same why are experts getting so many
things wrong today well first maybe
they're not experts but uh secondly the
trust in federal government has gone
down from the time of the Vietnam War
when the Vietnam War was uh was being
waged many people's lost confidence in
the government Watergate compounded that
yeah and then since that time we've had
a lot of government officials say a lot
of things are just not true and I think
the Trump Europe also had some impact on
that as well but also remember in the
old days when I was young you were not
even probably born we had a situation
where you had three news shows in the
evening that's where people got their
news CBS NBC and ABC no cable everybody
newspapers are very you know only a
couple newspapers that were really
National newspapers that's what you got
your news from now everybody's got a
podcast everybody's got a TV show
everybody's an interviewer uh everybody
watches things you know there should be
a bumper sticker say honk if you don't
have your own podcast
everybody's got a podcast everybody's
interviewer so there's so much
information coming into people you're
bound to be wrong and you're bound to
disappoint people so I don't know that
the experts are less good than they used
to be but the willingness of people to
accept Authority except the government
as knowing what it's doing or for
example take the most recent elections
everybody said it was gonna be a red
wave and the house was going to be
overwhelmingly Republican and the Senate
would go even would go Republican would
be dramatically wrong yeah people are
wrong yeah so but then also when you
were given the stories at the time when
I was in run and there was only three
shows you know how right now Tucker
Carlson's number one at 2.7 million at
the time number one was 33 million right
yeah right 33 million can you imagine
like you're the number one guy 33
million but to say the thing about
podcasts which
um
what did Jamie Diamond say to you in an
interview I love what he said to you he
says he said David uh uh this is the
interview you did when did you do the
interview with Jamie I've done several
of them over the years but um the one
what he talked about his relationship
with Sandy how hey I asked Sandy to go
to lunch after year and I sat down I
said let me tell you this is where you
were wrong here's the areas I was wrong
I thought it was a fascinating interview
yeah it was interesting five years ago
that was in 2017 when he did it that's
right and if there was an audience when
you were doing that interview with him
he said something he says he said David
we got 145 million people that are
working today give or take he says only
20 million they're working for the
government only 125 million are working
for uh uh what do you call a free
enterprise free market right and
whatever that number is 120 20 or 125 20
but the number was and he says the only
thing I think they get right in the
government is what military that's
Jamie's words what he said to you you've
done many interviews you may not
remember that but he said that in 2017.
so for me when I hear that I'm like okay
free enterprise gets things right more
than the government gets things right
they're not operators they don't know
how to build you give them money they
screwed up you give the money to you I
would trust giving you a billion dollars
and giving anybody at the White House a
billion dollars right so I think the one
thing that has happened in which the
honking part about the podcast
I'm loving that because we thought all
these years the best people on podcasts
and news were the guys that we were
supposed to admire and they were like no
a guy that's tatted who smokes weed and
likes UFC and was on fear fact a former
actor who can beat up 99.9 percent of
men in the street
he's embarrassing everybody the guy's
name is Joseph Rogan you know this guy's
kicking everyone's tail combined so I
think that whole concept about podcasts
what it did do is it got the rest of us
to kind of say listen if this this Dr
faucy thing got a lot of things wrong
that other expert gun Finance got a lot
of things all these people we were
supposed to trust men some of them are
full of [ __ ] because there's marketing
dollars Beyond and they got exposed and
I think that made a lot of people
uncomfortable because the club Behind
Closed Doors but we were all supposed to
be like look I understand we're going to
kind of respect what you're doing
because I know we're doing business and
we won't say anything about it but you
owe us a favor some of that stuff I
think now people are like holy moly
these guys are exposing the rest of us I
think it is a progress type of a
direction we're going in where people
can no longer be as I kind of like
experts being held accountable I like it
well there's no doubt that sometimes
there are no right answers so for
example let's suppose you had been Dr
fauci yeah
um at the beginning of covet what could
you have said or what would you have
done that would have made the world
better we didn't have a vaccine at the
beginning so we didn't really have a lot
of knowledge about what we could do
obviously the masks were one thing that
were done that's not a perfect solution
I think the government lost a lot of
trust when when we didn't really solve
the covet problem as quickly as maybe we
should have and we we did a lot of a
million Americans died we could have
done a better job I think everybody
would agree on that what do you think we
could have done differently though I
mean I know you and I are not doctors
but like okay let's just let's process
that and say what could we have done
differently you know never in the
history of mankind have we made a
vaccine faster yeah it's the fastest
ever yeah never have we like can you
imagine like to tell people I'm in the
military Mike you were just talking
about the Marines you know you guys yeah
60 000 soldiers and a little over 3 000
Marines kicked out and discharged with
other than honorable discharge it's a
general discharge for what reason for
not taking the vaccine okay I mean that
that that that part for me it wasn't
necessarily you know uh uh thought she
had been through the AIDS pandemic you
know epidemic right you know he had gone
through a lot of these things and he saw
what happened with AIDS he saw what
happened with a lot of these other
things and
the weirdest thing for me was when we
went from a country of you know choice
like you know how progressives say
pro-choice approach I like to Pro you
know this election submit terms you know
what it came down to you know that I
know that I mean we read it everywhere
no it's going to be this it's going to
be that's going to be economy is bad no
it came down to rho V weight and you
know if the Republicans strategically
would have done it later some are saying
McConnell intentionally forced it to
happen before because he wanted Trump to
get a black guy so the Republicans would
realize hey it's us really that are
running it not Trump you guys got to get
away from Trump so a little bit of
strategy credit maybe to McConnell if it
was intentional to get Roe Vape before
who knows but it was Choice even some
people on the other side wanted the
choice the part that made Americans a
little bit uncomfortable which was like
dude like listen I'll take the vaccine
God I've taken 30 vaccines in my life
just don't force it down my throat let
me have the choice to take it I don't
think there's anything else that could
have been different because you know how
long does it take to do research on a
vaccine you mean to tell me after nine
months of you doing testing on who on
animals maybe you want to now test it on
me and we've never done anything where
we need a three we've always had three
years of testing for vaccines unless you
want to expedite now you want me to
trust it 100 that's just a little bit
uncomfortable for an American to say yes
did you take the vaccine I did not but
everybody in my family did meaning my
dad did he's 80. my nanny did you know
my dad took five boosters he lives with
me did you get covered of course I got
covet yeah of course I I got covered the
I got the first covet I got covet
covered I didn't get Delta or I didn't
get uh that was the more serious one
yeah I got the real covet and I lost 21
pounds yeah I lost 21 pounds in four
weeks it we moved our entire office we
had 80 percent of our office at one
point get covered it sucked I'm not
sitting here telling you it was a you
know euphoric experience and everybody
should try it but I think the biggest
thing is
to to get people to be forced to do
something they didn't want to do I think
certain situations in the military we
did it wrong I think New York certain
things was wrong I was living in La for
24 years I left LA because they were
trying to control every decision I was
making I moved to Dallas so I left my
insurance headquarters in Dallas I was
just there yesterday we got back last
night at 8 30 Addison private
our office in Addison we like Addison
two years ago we moved here from Addison
to Fort Lauderdale right here
because I was watching everybody I'm
like dude what is so the best case
studies was Disneyland Disney World
perfect case study California Florida
one the perfect case study all the
people that were complaining in the NBA
about black lives matter they chose to
do playoffs in Florida I'm sorry aren't
you supposed to hate the state all the
people that politically hated what
DeSantis was doing in LA or New York or
Chicago for Christmas they were clubbing
here in Miami they all came vacation in
Miami so you watch some of this stuff
and they are like I don't know man and I
know you know it's made me feel very
uncomfortable that they were forcing
that's the only thing I thought was
uncomfortable why did you have your
children get it but no my my parents got
it my kids didn't get there no my kids
didn't get that uh the vaccine my kids
uh
you know I'm a guy that went to the
military when you're going to the
military first week we took 11 shots
they give it air guns and all this stuff
and if you go you just assembly line
yeah
shoulder no joke and if you which it
cuts you and our kids got the vaccines
got the vaccines but for me and the
reason why even some of the vaccines are
a little bit you know the whole story
with autism and how Robert De Niro was
at that one I don't know if you've seen
this interview where uh there was a
video that was done vaxed and he was
talking to the reporter that they
removed him and he was upset because he
didn't want to talk about it because
he's got a 22 year old son that has
autism and he thinks it's linked to
vaccine and you know Robert De Niro
cannot stand Trump but he just want to
learn a little bit more about that and
but for us like even that has Decades of
research we don't have Decades of
research on this for everybody to just
make you feel guilty if you don't want
to get a shot it's a little bit
uncomfortable well I I don't think
vaccines cause autism but there was a
report by a British doctor at one point
that's since been discredited who was
alleging that I don't think any
scientists that are reputable believe
that autism is caused by vaccines in my
view but I didn't say that I know it's
not what I was saying I know but but now
just to deal with that in terms of
vaccines about a third of Americans have
not been vaccinated against covet so
that shows you you know but the same
percentage is true in Europe too about a
third of people in Europe as well have
not been vaccinated there's a certain
percentage of people who just either
don't want to be told what to do or just
don't feel comfortable with it and
you're not going to change them but did
you see the data that's coming out that
some of the guys now
that are vaccinated are getting sicker
or they're getting covered more often
than the ones that they and by the way
this is not a Breitbart article or a
yeah box article I uh I I was vaccinated
all the time you could be vaccinated I
did get covet subsequent to that but
maybe it was more model case a milder
case I don't know so vaccines are not
perfect uh solutions to dealing with
these problems they can mitigate the
problem but they're not perfect but for
example all right you're vaccinated
against polio so that one you're you're
comfortable with because it's been
testified it's a research sure yeah I
think it's a research my only thing was
that so if for me uh you know you kind
of are able to say all right let me see
what's going how much research do we
have in this how many years okay great
perfect then let's go do this rather
than like can you guys give us some
natural maybe Eastern medicine without
having to put something on my body
that's a different way that's can we get
some of those Solutions why does it have
to be immediately this and then
the average person who's a little bit
skeptic is going to sit there and say
let me get this straight so your uh oh
you're sponsoring the guy that is giving
you millions of dollars of sponsorship
and you're saying we should take that
product well why would you tell us not
to take that product pick pharma's
advertising yeah well that makes sense
for you to support them because if you
don't you're not going to get that 52
million or 10 million dollar budget per
year okay I get your loyalty to the
money that you're getting it doesn't
make sense for me to do the sponsorship
about this company and after afterwards
I say by the way they suck I just want
to let you know this these guys are not
good but they gave us money so here's a
sponsorship so those are some of the
levels where I think the level of trust
in mainstream media went down because
they stopped doing one thing you know
why I love watching the interviews I
have a friend of mine a very successful
Armenians in La very
and they've made very good money okay
huh
oh they made very good money and they
will say Pat there's a lot of guys on
YouTube
you can name them all I only watch one
guy
who's the one guy he's the best Who
David Rubinstein I don't watch anybody
else but David tell me why
because David asked the questions I'm
thinking about
that's great so then I'm like I know
David but I didn't know David had a
YouTube this is five years ago we're not
talking about like this is when you just
had started you got a couple hundred
thousand Subs right now but at that time
you're just kidding so I'm like let me
see I'm like damn this is sick
this this guy keeps doing more
interviews so he's gonna have 10 million
Subs he's freaking legit and what are
the moral Authority does somebody give
you to be sitting on all these boards
and these people you've dealt with like
you met presidents all of them probably
you met billionaires probably all the
Fortune 500 guys you probably met most
of the CEOs your clients some of them
are some of the most powerful people in
the world that you're dining your
president stays at one of your places
you've you've met all these guys Jimmy
Carter so you've worked in all these
different spaces fantastic
the one thing that I got uncomfortable
with was the final one
at the beginning of covid I have no idea
what's going on we're in L.A we have a
board meeting it's March 12th or 13th
that's the day when NHL shutdown NBA
shut down Disneyland show I'm in LA with
three of my kids
and I'm getting ready to take my kids to
Universal Studios we love going to
Universal Studios and we have a board
meeting with Gabrielle brender and and
uh Greg chair Greg Sharon Oscar De La
Hoya okay cool I'm gonna do the board
meeting then we're gonna go to uh you
know uh whatever Universal Studios so
we're staying at Beverly Hills Beverly
Hills whatever the hotel is
and then first person cancels second
person cancels but I'm like what are you
guys doing hey it's because of uh covet
covet yeah seriously yeah
let's turn on the news let me read it
listen babe we got to go back because
everybody's afraid right now let's see
what's going on
should I go back and I go into research
mode first thing I do I got a podcast
with a few million subscribers
let me call people from both sides to
come and discuss this solution vaccine
all this stuff at this point I have no
clue what's going on I got to make the
right decision for my field I gotta make
the right decision for my Executives or
my family do I take the vaccine do I not
take the vaccine you know what was one
of the biggest reasons why I didn't take
the vaccine here's what I'll tell you
the guys
who were skeptical about not taking it
like RFK Robert Kennedy Jr you know who
he is and others they were willing to
debate anybody but when I called Dr Paul
offit when I called all these other
doctors
a hundred and I told them I'll give you
10 grand then I went to 20 grand any
charity 50 Grand 100 Grand they would
not take the debate to meet Robert
Kennedy Jr to discuss this that's when I
said something's off
and then there was a guy named Dr Mike
who's got a YouTube channel I think he's
got you can pull them up seven or eight
million subscribers
so he calls me out and uh calls out an
interview I do with a girl named with a
lady named Dr Judy mikovitz which I
don't know who she is but I interview
her because I'm interviewing all the
doctors at the time that only gets taken
out real quick he gets a million views
gets taken down he's texting me and he
says yeah absolutely I'll do I'll do
debate her anytime any day or uh Bookers
like he's booked he's coming three times
he confirms all of a sudden last minute
no I don't want to talk to her why I'm
too busy really while he was busy he
took 20 different interviews from other
people we have a hard time interviewing
you know and I thought you went on this
show God knows how many times right on
his YouTube channel
and I'm a street guy you know I'm a guy
that came from the streets divorce
family my parents got divorced twice
I've seen drugs I've seen everything
I've seen gangs I've been around all
these different gangs and lesson man
that's a anytime you don't want to face
off somebody there's a little bit of
fear or concern that you got and who's
RFK like a gangster is he a mobster is
it going to come after your family [ __ ]
everybody went after his family not your
family sit down with the guy that's when
I said
I don't know what's going on I'm not an
expert in this space I'm not a doctor
I'm not a scientist
but anytime you're not willing to sit
with some other debate a topic like a
qualified person like this or other
doctors that I even invited
they lost a lot of trust with me because
all they want all these experts ever
wanted to talk to was people that agreed
with them and that made me very
uncomfortable
well I can understand that but sometimes
people don't want to debate people
because they don't want to give them an
audience that they wouldn't otherwise
wouldn't have and and for example if you
if somebody says I'm a virulent
anti-semite I hate Jews
should you debate them about why Jews
are not so bad if they're reasonable
well but you're when you do when you
give an audience to people who otherwise
wouldn't have it you're really helping
some people get a message to people that
I think is a damaging message sometimes
so you would you wouldn't presumably
invite going to the show some people who
say things that are let's say verily
anti-semitic you wouldn't do that I
agree I agree but RFK
RFK like really I by the way and it's
such a great Point you're making because
some of them are like that and and I
filter those guys out very quickly where
they come in and say let me tell you
guarantee you know it's this and it's
like I don't know if you know this guy
named David Ike I don't know if you've
seen some of his interviews I brought
some of these I'm like first of all let
me get this straight you believe in
reptilian people you believe in this you
believe in this and you believe in this
before I ask you any questions I think
it's important for the audience to know
what you really believe in yes he got
upset what does that have to do with
anything I said your credibility has to
be stated before we ask any questions
I'm not going to get a guy like that to
debate somebody from the other side I
look for reasonable people not by the
way he's got a big follow a lot of
people follow his stuff and they say
half his conspiracy theories are right
you know but at the beginning if you
remember was linked to 5G and these 5G
networks and all this stuff that was the
whole thing that was going on that
people were worried about but uh when
when two reasonable people are afraid to
sit down against each other one like
Thomas Soul against uh uh what's the
other guy's name that I had an interview
with what's the other uh socialist
Economist slash uh communist Economist
who's got a very very big following
aoc's hero what's what's his name
I had him on the podcast you'd know who
he is are you no I love talking to
Richard Wolff I don't know if you know
who Richard Wolff is he's a socialist
Professor according to Forbes the number
one socialist Professor no this guy was
a pure communist at the UC Riverside I
liked him a lot uh debating him as that
he can play the video because it's ours
it's it's someone you guys all know
everybody knows this gnome Chomsky I'm
sorry gnome Chomsky you know who Norm
Chomsky is
do you know who Thomas soul is okay you
know Thomas Solis you know Hoover
Institute you know coming from the
lineage of the great Milton Friedman
and I say no you know a lot of people
say you're afraid to debate to Thomas
soul is that true
and his physiology changed
okay to me you lost the fight
because whose time is so what is so
scary about tomasoli is an economist and
he's in his 90s
well you know my schedule's very busy so
is his once you reach a certain level I
think it's fair to say your schedule is
very busy I think it's fair to say that
you have a lot of different options
you're taking time to come here salute a
lot of respect for you so I always watch
like even boxing I don't know if you
follow boxing or not when a guy doesn't
want to face another guy to box
why don't you want to face him so that's
the skepticism for that by the way this
whole thing's coming about the level of
trust we have in the US government or
mainstream Media or experts that's kind
of how this conversation started I know
how we got into vaccine but uh my my
lack of trust came from people not
wanting to debate anymore
my entire Mi grew up in a family where
my mothers were Communists my entire
mother's family were Communists 100 our
Bible growing up was a Communist
Manifesto and my dad was an imperialist
one love to Shah one love Stalin and
Lennon
so it was a house filled with debate and
I'm in the middle so forget Hillary
against Trump like this was the best
debate I was here every night my mom and
dad debating so I enjoy a good debate we
get closer to the truth so the last
couple years
what was always America's DNA we kind of
got away from the debate concept made me
very uncomfortable
all right well now you're going to deal
with that what are you gonna do now
I'm doing what I'm doing right now with
the media side I'm taking all my money
that I'm making and I'm going to build a
media platform where people with courage
like you who are willing to ask the
questions we show them respect and at
the same time have tough conversations
for the audience to get off and say I
agree I disagree I'm not born here so I
can't run for office but we're gonna
we're gonna compete in the media space
to make sure the right conversations are
held and hopefully people who also
support debate right will entertain that
idea okay
all right so can we talk about about my
book yeah absolutely all right
absolutely so uh before we go into how
to invest would you mind if I ask you a
couple other questions about the economy
just purely about the economy before we
get into the book so uh when we're
talking unemployment we talked
unemployment already uh we talked uh
what do you call a debate already we
talked uh uh inflation already okay so
here's one to talk about Americans
expect worsening in U.S economy in 2023.
this is Wall Street Journal okay uh
where the American people are at what
direction the economy is going in you
know what's going to happen with it how
much of what you think uh
the American people's concerns about
what economies at matches what's
actually going to happen next year well
I don't think anybody really knows
what's going to happen in 2023 you know
there's an old saying in Hollywood in
fact an author the man who was the uh
scriptwriter for Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid
um he wrote a book and title was nobody
here knows anything which means you
never know when a movie is going to be
successful or not well the same is true
true in the economy nobody really knows
you can have experts here and there but
nobody really knows it's a guessing game
we can't determine when the war in
Ukraine is going to be over who knows
when that's going to be over that'll
change the economy is China going to
invade Taiwan that'll affect the economy
we just don't know or the Republicans
going to go try to impeach Joe Biden we
don't know that could have an impact on
the economy it delays the Congress in
passing other things who knows so I
would say right now the conventional
wisdom and the conventional wisdom is
often generally wrong in Washington but
the conventional wisdom in Washington is
that we'll probably have a recession
question in 2023 mild recession
unemployment will go up somewhat
Congress won't pass that many bills to
anything that's going to spend a lot
more money because that's we've already
spent all the money we pretty much can
afford to spend and I would say
um I don't I think the American people
when they read as much as they read
about the economy going to recession
recession eventually they kind of
reflect that in the public opinion polls
and that's why people are saying they're
worried about the economy but people are
always worried about the economy there's
never a time when people are not worried
about the economy so I don't know that
it'll be as bad as we had in 2007 2008
2009 but it could go down but remember
economies always come back recession's
always end and the world comes back and
they usually the U.S economy comes back
very very strong we still have an
incredibly strong economy now compared
to Europe and compared to China our
economy is growing much better than
China and and Europe is so
um I'm not pessimistic about the U.S
economy and when it goes down it will it
will be Rebound in my view so I'm not
that worried about the economy there are
bigger things to worry about Tom you had
a question Matt both
so in 2008 you you certainly it was far
far worse than what we've seen here and
we probably haven't even seen the you
know the worst of whatever this
recession nobody can
can get there because things
historically that were constants become
variables and then variables become
constants and everybody's algebra Falls
over
um you had said in 2008 you talked about
hey you know when all the banks when all
this debt is with the banks in other
words it's all becomes organized
um all the tarp and everything becomes
the finance we're going to enter into a
platinum age for private Equity it
turned out to be very very quick
although things are not that way now
what do you see happening after we get
through call it a blip call a mini
recession whatever we think what is your
crystal ball
for what where we're going to go you
talked about the private Equity or for
or for or for the economy generally well
you were you were correct about private
equity and you were in that business and
you selected it but is there anything
out there that you're looking at right
now that you say you know what this is
what I see and I and I'm feeling well I
think the economy if it if it goes into
recession we'll have a rebound and when
we come out I think the economy will
continue to grow at a reasonable Pace
remember we have a 22 trillion dollar
GDP so economy's big it's hard to grow
that at 10 a year hard to grow that at
even seven percent a year uh we we
briefly grown in at six percent a year
coming back out of uh six percent a
quarter coming out of uh out of some
parts of covet but right now I think
giving the economy's size you're growing
two or three percent a year that's
pretty good I think we can we can
continue to do that but that happens
when people feel like they have an
incentive to go to work they have an
incentive to invest the government
doesn't do some things that I think
backfire on
um right now the biggest problem the
country has in my view aside from the
racial problems we have and the legacy
of slavery and and all all the other
kinds of
problems that exist between you know
certain sectors of the economy people in
the who are born into poverty are never
going to escape the biggest problem we
have is a dysfunction of the government
right now the Democrats and Republicans
just cannot agree on almost anything
maybe they'll agree on a spending bill
here or there but generally uh it's
dysfunctional when I worked on Capitol
Hill briefly in the late 70s a
bipartisan bill was considered to be a
good thing if you were a good legislator
you actually knew how to get Democrats
Republicans come together if now you're
on one party or you're the other party
you're not supposed to really talk to
people from the other party or work with
them and I think that's unfortunate yeah
and that's one of the biggest problems
this country has it's so
um acrimonious in Washington DC now that
you don't get people even socializing
anymore with people from the opposite
party I wish that would change
my observation of your book you know
you've interviewed a lot of people that
didn't come from wealth yeah you
included and and when you're looking at
the commonalities between all of them
how to invest I'm looking at the typical
person right now trying to save in their
401K none of you all in that book really
saved you guys all invest right well
look they're different things so their
book was written for diff this was a
book called how to invest and obviously
you're not going to read that book and
become Warren Buffett just like you're
not going to read a book by
um Tiger Woods and become a great golfer
you can't read a book and all of a
sudden change your life that
dramatically but this is designed for
young students who want to consider a
career investing or for the average
person and not the superstars uh for the
average person who has a reasonable
amount of excess income they probably
shouldn't try to be Warren Buffett by
all of a sudden picking stocks
themselves picking bonds themselves they
probably should give their money to a
money manager and probably best to put
it in an index fund which will track the
market because the average person who
makes fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars a year is not gonna
quadruple their net worth by picking
stocks here and there you're just not
going to beat the market averages so be
with the market average and be the go
with an index fund there's a low fee
that's what the average person should
really do in my view when you
interviewed uh Mary calendar and Erdos
right she she goes on record saying that
you know there's 2200 analysts starting
there's a two or three year training
program and if you're going to master
something 10 000 hours if you're going
to work a typical job it's going to take
you five years to master something she
goes on record by saying in Wall Street
it's 12 hours a day six days a week in
two to three years your master something
she got a lot of pushback because of
that are we in a generation right now
where people don't want to put in the
work and put in the effort to start
mastering things I think they're always
going to be people with ambition and
always people want to get ahead in life
at least in this country some people may
rebel against that there are some people
in the youngest generation who now say
look I want to work 20 hours a week and
I work from home and I'm not going to
the office and but you know those people
will be left behind in my view I think
there are people ambitious who want to
get ahead in life Mary Erdos for those
who don't know runs to JP Morgan private
wealth business which is roughly a four
trillion dollar business and she's
managing money for the wealthiest people
in the country she's a heavyweight she's
not just anybody she's a serious person
and uh one of the you know I tried in
the book to make it clear you don't have
to be an old white man to be an
investment professional who's good so I
had uh people from Minority backgrounds
people are women and I and I think
there'll be more of them if I wrote this
book 10 years from now there might not
be that many white males in it because
the business is changing
in your perspectives of investing I
looked at you know you had nine of them
you had luck price due diligence
Instinct management Etc when you talk
about price you mentioned in that Aspen
your perspective that you've heard that
company's management team prefers you as
their investor they're going to choose
you talk to me about leadership and talk
to me about management well the point I
was making there is when we're doing a
buyout uh you're competing everything is
an auction pretty much and when uh
somebody my team comes to me and says
our the management team or the company
want to buy they prefer us well they're
often not the people making the decision
it's the owner and so when people tell
me that the the seller or the management
team prefers us I get skeptical a bit
because they're not necessarily the
decision maker
um so I I just think in the end what
gets down to when you're trying to buy a
company is pretty much the price and the
certainty of closing at that price
um you know maybe people are like you a
little bit more maybe in some cases it
makes a modest difference but generally
in the buyout World whoever pays the
highest price with a certainty of
closing is almost certainly going to win
that deal because people I experienced
that with you and then this exit we've
had that you prefer to certain investor
to purchase PHP it wasn't just any
because there's a lot of money there's a
lot of offers coming your way but I saw
you look for example if I'm buying a
company they want you to buy them right
because they feel that you're going to
take the business to the next level and
that's kind of the perspective you had
it depends if you're controlling the
company if you're buying 100 of the
company the seller probably doesn't care
that much if you were they're going to
stay in the deal then they want somebody
they think is going to add value then
they might look at something other than
price because they're still going to
ride with the upside
right he's right he that's exactly it
because uh you have to think about the
people that have been running a company
who are going to be with the new buyer
longer than the founder maybe so it's
important for that partnership to make
sense and then the structure to be set
up you know sometimes uh it's set up in
a way where the founder doesn't go with
the deal they don't even want the
founder to go with the deals like listen
kind of step out of the way you've been
partying too much you're kind of living
a lifestyle the whole yacht all this
other stuff you're not you haven't been
operating for four years let us just
take over and we'll do our part and then
sometimes if the founder is very
involved they kind of want the guy to be
locked in a little bit for a couple
years before they transition them out
that's true um sometimes if it's a
Founder it's a difference if it's a
founder and a CEO if it's a Founder but
he is not really still running the
company they'd probably be happy if he
would lend his credibility to the
customers say I'm still happy with this
buyer I'm still around but they don't
really want to his advice that much they
don't want him involved that much if
it's a CEO who's really built the
company and is still running at a
company and is really valuable you
probably would keep him for a while but
in a buyout about more than 50 percent
of the time the person who's running the
company in a buyout at the time you do
the deal is not running it when you exit
that deal that totally makes sense and
and some people would say the biggest
mistake that buyout firms make is
staying with a CO too long sometimes the
CEO was good maybe before or maybe
wasn't that good but if you keep riding
with him for too long or her too long it
generally doesn't work and very often
you make you make changes right why is
that why is that because operating a
buyout company with Leverage is
different than operating one without
leverage also people have different
philosophies and somebody if you built
your this company this company you now
own you built it it's your baby and
let's suppose you sell it tomorrow you
say look I know everything here why
would you not want to keep me and they
would say well you're nice but now it's
our money at risk and our money at risk
is different and we have different ways
of doing things now sometimes they might
say we want to keep you for a while to
keep the customers happy to make certain
that there's no transition people
employees aren't leaving right away yeah
but after a while they'll say you know
you know you don't need to come into
work 40 hours a week maybe maybe 30
hours a week or maybe 20 hours a week
maybe 10 hours a week and by the way you
know we're going to call you chairman
emeritus and by the way
um your parking spot's gone now at some
point you know they don't need you so
much that's what happens in life what's
what's the difference between a way of
Founders wired versus a CEO's wired like
what what do you see to say I don't
think this founder is going to is a real
CEO like what's the difference between
those our founder is willing to take
entrepreneurial risks when you take an
entrepreneurial risk you're betting a
lot on something happening and if it
doesn't work out you lose a lot more the
CEO is basically getting a salary and
maybe some stock incentives and so forth
but he or she you know will will
transition to some other job and they
can run another company the founder has
more of his heart and soul in it as a
generally uh principle and so when you
build something it's much different than
if you're running something
that makes sense that makes sense uh
right now do you think uh uh this whole
situation with Elam buying Twitter
uh are you guys optimistic about what's
going to happen with the Twitter
evaluation are you kind of like yeah
it's not something we're interested in
how are you viewing what elon's doing
I'm not an investor in in in in the
company so I can give you that that
perspective without being an investor I
think
he paid a high price in other words what
happened is he bought the company at a
agree to buy the company and that the
tech transition occurred and the tech
evaluations went down so he paid
probably 25 percent more than the
company was really worth uh he knew that
but he thought he could turn around
because he's an engineering uh Marvel
and so forth he then made some changes
and now a CEO that have really taken
away a lot of the customers a lot of the
uh a lot of the advertisers yeah I think
the company cannot service its debt or
normally it takes about a billion
dollars a year uh to service the debt of
the the debt that he borrowed he bought
about I think 11 billion dollars he he
takes about a billion dollars a year to
service that debt they're not earning a
billion dollars a year so what's going
to happen he'll either have to subsidize
it and pay it out of his own proceeds he
could take the company bankrupt the
problem with taking the company bankrupt
is this
um in the end the senior debt will own
the company so he will have lost a lot
of money the 11 billion yes 11 billion
would own the company but remember he
could go buy that 11 billion at a
discount the the banks would probably
the banks are carrying that data by 80
cents from a dollar he could probably
buy it at 70 cents on a dollar so he
buys the debt he then owns a company he
could bankrupt the company he then owns
the company because all the equity is
wiped out of course his friends are in
the equity and he's in the equity so
it's a big loss either way there's no
easy way out of this in my view other
than kind of getting the the revenue
back up again it's a tough tough slog
and I I don't envy him trying to run
this company he's remember he's also
running two other companies that's right
that's right it's enough to run one
company he's running two other big
companies and both of those are pretty
successful building companies yeah
somebody the story that came out saying
the third largest Tesla stock owner says
Elon Musk should step down as the CEO
this story just came out because some of
these other guys from they're like dude
what are you doing we believe in Tesla
with you running it right Indonesian
billionaire uh kugan Leo the third
largest individual shareholder Tesla
accuses musk of uh focusing too heavily
on Twitter Elon abandoned Tesla and
Tesla has as uh no working CEO Tesla
needs and deserves to have a fully
working CEO full-time working CEO Leo
went on to suggest that the Tesla board
of directors was obligated to look for
replacement the billionaire suggested
that must be given the opportunity to
find and name his successor with the
independent supervision of the board he
added Elon was the proud father Tesla
has grown up an executioner Tim
cook-like is needed not Elon yes now and
what's happened is the market cap of
Tesla was probably at its peak 1.1
trillion dollars and that made him the
richest man in the world because he was
the biggest shareholder of it today I
think the market cap is maybe closer to
500 billion so it's lost about half its
value why well one thing is that he sold
a number of his shares in order to buy
Twitter so whenever you sell shares it
depresses the price and now people think
that he's not focused on it and
therefore he's not the genius behind us
and a lot of people are selling so it's
lost easily he's lost half of the value
of the company and that's why some of
the shareholders aren't happy so you
think the idea of bringing a Tim Cook is
a good idea like what he's suggesting
well I think somebody needs to be
running the company whether Elon Musk is
willing to give up running the company I
don't know I'm not involved in it but I
I I'd say that somebody should be the
company somebody should be running
SpaceX too
um you know it's hard to run one company
once and how do you do that how do you
run three companies a billion auto
companies simultaneously well he put a
lot of his personal Fortune into uh into
uh Twitter he wants to turn it around he
realizes now it's tougher to turn around
than he thought so right now the
company's in somewhat uh disarray but
you know he's done a really good job of
building these companies before maybe
even up with enough time he can he can
make Twitter turn around take some time
but by the way how do you what do you
think about what Tim Cook did with apple
would you put him at the top as the best
CEO in the market today
when Steve Jobs died the market cap of
Apple was roughly 350 billion dollars
more or less now the market cap is what
1.1 trillion or to 1.2 trillion
something like that at one point so what
he did is uh is staggering
um I'd say apple reached three trillion
dollars at one point valuation what is
it right now by the way well it's it's
probably oh oh there you go 2.1 trillion
today okay so um so the the market cap
is now about uh four six seven times
what it was when he inherited the
company
um he did a spectacular job I've
interviewed him he's a terrific person
um I'd say right now there was a survey
done by the Wall Street Journal of who
is the best CEO today and he certainly
was one of the top I think uh Sacha
Nadella who's run Microsoft when he took
over Microsoft that company stock hadn't
moved in 10 years 10 years now the stock
is up like 10 times uh what he what he
did to make Microsoft much more valuable
than ever been is staggering so he is
one of the best CEOs out there in my
view and Tim Cook is another one Tom you
always talk about him you always give
credit to him yeah what's amazing is you
know whether you look at inflated
dollars or not I mean Tim Cook has
generated more shareholder value than
any CEO in the history of the American
experiment and it's just even if you
discount up for inflation and do all the
adjustments it's phenomenal spectacular
job he's done and remember when he took
over as CEO people didn't think he could
do this because he was not the Superstar
uh public figure that's that Steve Jobs
was but he was more mild-mannered he was
basically known as a supply chain person
but he's done a spectacular job and I
would say he
um and and such and Adele have both done
turnarounds or companies much more
valuable than they were before have you
read the book after Steve
no I have not he just came out if it's a
very very interesting book and most of
it is about Tim Cook very very
insightful he's uh uh I I know him
reason why when I was chairman of the
board of Duke I put him on the Duke
board and uh you know he he was a
graduate of the Duke University Business
School
top five books that impacted you the
most like what what are some books that
uh where you when your kids ask you Dad
give me five books I should read what
would those five books be they probably
wouldn't be my books
I don't think my kids have read any any
of my books look if you're on a desert
island and you only have one book what
book would you take probably you take
the Bible because the Bible has so many
things about human life and and the way
humans have gotten together over the
years and interacted with everybody then
the Bible is an unusual and book when
you think about it 75 of it is the Old
Testament
um 25 is the New Testament but in both
the Old and New Testament uh you know
there are a lot of a lot of wisdom in
there I just think that's probably one
book you would probably want to want to
have with you uh maybe one of your books
I don't know yeah I mean I want to know
what you're going to see if I'm on an
island I got the Bible that's pretty
good if I got the business books on an
island with no Market no technology I'm
screwed like I probably need a big book
that I can mix on fire like give me the
biggest book of all time
what else would you say you've read a
lot I mean you I do read a lot of books
because I have programs where I
interview authors and I think to to an
interview author I generally like to
read the book so I'm just reading a
number of books now for interviews I'm
going to do I just did an interview the
day of of uh the man who led the raid on
uh Bill mcraven Bill leather raid to
capture Osama Bin Laden he had a book
called South uh C stories and
interviewing him it's incredible how we
caught Osama Bin Laden and how he and at
the time we caught him they didn't know
we actually had him and so what happened
was
um they had to take him out of his body
bag Admiral that's him he gave a speech
that was viral that's uh University of
Texas yeah make your bed you were saying
well what happened was they captured him
they put him in the body bag they bring
them back and they unzip the body bag
they pull them out and say oh is this
Osama Bin Laden was beard looks shorter
than than they thought we weren't sure
they knew he was six foot four but they
didn't so they didn't have a tape
measure so they sold another sailor
there he said sailor how tall are you
six foot two come over here lie down
next to this guy oh you look like you're
two inches shorter so he called
President Obama and President Obama and
said uh like we think it's him we
haven't done the DNA test but I just had
a soldier or sailor lie down next to him
who was six foot two this guy looks two
inches bigger so I think it's him and
Obama said well wait a second you had a
90 million dollar helicopter and you
didn't pick a ten dollar tape measure
with you why didn't you do that and so
when when he met with Obama in the Oval
Office later he Obama gave him a tape
measure that's a what a good story right
there what a good story right there 90
million here's 10 bucks go measure it
next time instead of putting a guy
laying next to him what else so we got
two books so far give me another one
give me give me one that's an evergreen
one not one that was just written like
something you read where you're like
because look if there's something that a
lot of people wanted like first of all
everybody has to read the book how to
invest especially if you want to get
into the business because you're
learning from 30 different people's
philosophies right it's not like you're
learning from one person by the way one
thing that was very interesting is how
everyone talked about Warren Buffett
like everybody edified him and gave him
a ton of credit everybody was it's as if
they're talking about would you say he's
the Michael Jordan of that industry yes
and the reason is this he has averaged
20 a year for 60 years 60 years
not 20 a year for two years three years
60 years I mean that's incredible what
he's done as an investor nobody's quite
ever done that and now he's still doing
this when he's in his 90s early 90s so
that's incredible if you want to read a
book about him there are a lot of great
books and more books about it here but
Warren Buffett probably than Abraham
Lincoln if that's possible but I would
say uh the book called snowball was
probably the best one on Warren Buffett
really really good book uh Warren
Buffett hasn't really written his own
book in that that sense uh another book
I've
um you know read recently um
there's a man named Sid Mukherjee who
wrote a book called uh the Emperor of
all maladies about cancer and it was a
really well written book it won the
Pulitzer Prize his first book on the
Pulitzer Prize he has a new book out
called the song of the cell his third
book the first book was on cancer second
book is on uh on genes third book is on
cells it's on New York Times bestseller
list right now
um I've just that's it
no that's the first one that one that
one uh won the Pulitzer Prize in his
first book which is pretty good the ring
your first book to win a Pulitzer Prize
and when he I just interviewed a moment
it's called the song of the cell which
is his latest book and um I've just
interviewed another great author John
Meacham and Meacham has a new book out
at the number one best bestseller on
Abraham Lincoln and uh you know more
books I've written about Abraham Lincoln
anybody other than Jesus Christ so it's
incredible and uh but he has a lot of
good insights in it I'm just finishing a
book uh that I'm interviewing the author
on Maggie Haberman who wrote a book
about uh Donald Trump it's a quite
interesting book on insights about
Donald Trump they're the infinite number
of Trump's books but this one is uh
she's covered him for the New York Times
for four years and it's a pretty
interesting book that's it confidence
man yeah I saw that one I saw that one
uh uh
I saw that one yeah why do you think
people are so enamored by this guy good
bad and ugly is it because he's like a
complicated personality very unusual
person I I do know him I I met with him
you know when he was president a number
of times and uh I would say uh it's
unusual
um unusual person usually people become
president United States have some
government back when he didn't have any
background in government so it was a
unusual situation but uh we'll see what
happens there out of all the
personalities you sat down with who who
is like the one where you would say this
guy
you know if he wanted to he could be a
president out of all the person you've
met what a lot of Leaders with strong
personalities have to be strong
negotiators processors who's that woman
if this guy ran I think he would win
well not not now but in his day um I
think he would have been a great
president he was in my firm for a number
of years Jim Baker he had been secretary
of state Secretary of Treasury Chief of
Staff under Ronald Reagan 12 years on
blemished record practically in in
federal service he's now 93 or 94. not
obviously going to be running for
president but he was an incredible
person was in our firm for quite some
time and I I really admired him
um and did you read his book did you
read he there's a book written about him
thousand page book 1100 page book well
his the book he wrote right after he
left
um I did read it but he wrote a second
book which I found better which is more
about politics and so forth the second
book I enjoyed more the the book that's
written about him
um the man who ran Washington that's the
one I couldn't put it down the Peter
Baker yeah yeah Peter Baker wrote his
with his wife with his wife that book is
uh that book's a really good book and
and I think it's a really good read on
how Washington works and how one man who
didn't have a real history in Washington
wasn't really a politician
um he came to Washington because his
best friend George Bush was helping get
a job there and all of a sudden
um yeah he became very very prominent in
Washington did a great job as chief of
staff from Ronald Reagan considered the
gold standard to be Chief of Staff you
go on record saying that you the
greatest American is in the greatest
president is Abraham Lincoln there's no
doubt about it what is some of those
personality traits do you think that
could be adaptable in today in 2022
um Abraham Lincoln held the country
together at that time most people would
have said the South you want to go away
go away because you know it wasn't easy
to say we're going to fight a civil war
of this in part because the truth is the
Civil War was not fought by the north to
uh free the slaves that wasn't the
Israel Mission it was to hold the union
together later he did the Emancipation
Proclamation which was done as a war
measure to help him win the war because
he was going to have 200 000 black
soldiers fighting for the union which he
did and ultimately helped win the war
Abraham Lincoln had a number of great
qualities but one of them was one we
haven't talked about which is humility
Abraham Lincoln didn't go to forge
theater the night before he was asking
and say you know what I won the world I
won the Civil War how am I great how
great am I um he didn't brag about
himself he had a lot of humility and I
think humility is a is a great virtue
and he had a lot of self-deprecating
humor uh that he would bring to the case
you know he would say you know people
say I'm two-faced well if I had two
faces why would I wear this one because
um he had a he had a he was the person
who held the country together there's no
doubt that the country would not have
stayed together without Lincoln most
politicians would not have done what he
did so I think he was the greatest
American when he became a president you
know was it a Buchanan uh
so he would say listen slavery is
something I'm going to work with and go
with he was kind of looking forward to
just like the same thing yeah see the
13th amendment abolished slavery uh that
came about at the end of Lincoln's
tournament right it was passed by
Congress a couple days before he was
assassinated but in the uh when James
Buchanan who was uh you know not a great
president maybe one of her weakest ever
he supported something called the Corwin
Amendment which was the 13th Amendment
as it was intended to be that said
slavery is the law of the land and don't
it can't be changed in the in the
existing states that have it Lincoln in
his inaugural address the first one he
endorsed that because he thought he had
to make it clear to people in the South
look I'm not trying to get rid of slaves
that's I I just don't want slavery to be
expanded to the other states the western
states but in your States it's in the
Constitution we're going to keep that
and Lincoln said that in his inaugural
address now obviously he evolved over a
period of time but Lincoln was not an
abolitionist by far he was not there
were many people who wanted to abolish
slavery he was not one of them and
what's your favorite Lincoln book
I think the uh probably well I think
that John Nation one is really good but
Doris current is good when uh the Team
of Rivals which was made into the
Lincoln movie yep is is a spectacular
book but she you know there are 10 000
books on Lincoln and I asked our parents
Goodwin why did you think the world
needed another one but she came up with
a novel concept that Lincoln was so
secure that he took people who were his
Rivals for the uh for the presidency and
he put them in the cabinet and and they
ultimately they became people who had
initially thought he was nothing but now
they became to admire him greatly do you
think there'll be a time where we'll
have a Republican president and a
democratic VP or a Democratic president
and a republican VP you think because I
think it happened one time what was the
year when a candidate had a opposing
party VP that they're running with there
was somebody that happened this and by
the way this wasn't too long ago this
was like 50 60 years ago seven years ago
you think we'll have that ever happen
um it's hard to see because right in the
old days the original way the
Constitution was originally set up
whoever had the most votes for president
got got to be president whoever the
second most became vice president we've
changed the Constitution so that
probably is harder to do now but look
maybe to get a unified ticket somebody
you could do that but on the other hand
the vice president doesn't have that
much power relative to president so I'm
not sure the the vice president's party
would think it's a good consolation but
nothing's impossible who could say
what's impossible that would be that
would be very by the libertarian party
still runs that way a guy that got the
most votes becomes a candidate and a
second Tom I'll give you the last
question before we wrap up any questions
you have yeah you know in your your book
on investing and it's I I think what you
just said about going to the Young
Generation where it goes and everything
um you know a lot of people and I was
curious about it is is kind of the
forecast on you follow government and
this is a nonpartisan thing also
security Medicare and the entitlement
how to structurally we have to change as
a nation so that we can we can serve all
that because this is this this mass of
people that are retiring yes that that
deserve to get what they paid for
literally out of their tax well remember
we have a pay-as-you-go system which
means we have no money
um so when you pay your Social Security
every week that's going to pay you know
you know somebody else's grandmother or
something because there's no real money
there's no lock box there's no trust
fund
when people when Social Security was set
up in 1933 the average life expectancy
in the United States was 65. when could
you collect your Social Security at 65.
so that not that many people were living
we live in the Catholic now it's like 82
83. so you now people are living for a
long time and you're collecting Social
Security we don't have enough money to
to be able to keep paying it right now
of the budget the entitlement part of
the budget is with defense spending
entitlements and interest it's roughly
80 percent of the budget 80 85 percent
of the budget so only about 15 is left
for everything else so at some point
you're going to have to do one of three
things you either cut the the benefits
you increase taxes or you basically have
to increase the amount of money that
you're going to borrow you're going to
borrow more money or you further extend
when they can get the Social Security
yeah you can do that too but you're
gonna have to borrow more money we have
31 trillion dollars of debt now 31
trillion that's you know that's not all
the commitments though that's just the
debt that we have that's the debt yeah
that's the debt and that's the money
we've already borrowed the future
commitments are staggering but we have a
higher percentage of debt uh to GDP than
any country in the world product except
maybe Italy which is not a great role
model no it's not so uh so right now the
only way you're going to solve this
problem is you've got to cut benefits
you could extend the age it's a way of
cutting benefits you have to
um you have to increase taxes or you
just borrow keep borrowing more money
there's no other way around it
you have a follow-up on that because for
me you know what I look at sometimes I'm
like okay you know the the American
economy is this it's strong we're this
we're that
I mean how the hell do we eventually
right after that like what happens when
we get interest rates are going up right
now and what if we can't make the
payments because because the you know to
Japan or China one of them we owe 1.1
trillion which I think is Japan China I
think we own oh one trillion these are
not small interest payments that we have
to make what happens when we default on
those things when well hopefully we
never default but when when the interest
rate is essentially zero yeah you can
borrow a lot of money
and so the federal government was paying
maybe three percent of the budget for
interest
now the interest rates are going up
we're paying six and seven percent of
the budget for interest because if rates
are going up 31 trillion dollars that's
a lot of money and we only had 15 to
play with of the remaining budget that's
about it how long is that sustainable
though
there's only one way out of it it's you
inflate your way out of the economy out
of it that's the only way out because
we're not going to default that's
unrealistic yeah we're not going to
increase taxes that's very hard to do we
can do it occasionally it's not easy to
cut spending where you're going to cut
it so you're not going to go to the IMF
for a bailout so in the end you're going
to flight your way out of it that's the
only way out of it you're not going to
default
I have a follow-up question for you know
for the common Joe out there it's it's
watching this podcast you know the the
Fidelity came out the report that said
the average savings of baby boomers
today is 138 000 for retirement Gen X 98
000 Millennials 63 000 gen Z 37 000. in
your opinion is the typical person
attempting to save for a retirement are
they getting crushed right now for the
future or do they have to do something
like you know we have a very low savings
rate in this country compared to other
countries very low savings rate we have
a consumer economy we encourage people
to buy things how people don't save them
much if you want to reduce our trade
deficit tell people to to save more but
we don't do that it's just because it's
thought to be uh you know difficult to
get people to save more that's a real
problem and a lot of people in this
country are living paycheck to paycheck
a very high percentage or increasingly
living paycheck to paycheck there are a
lot of problems in in the lower part of
the economic strata for sure and it's
not changing overnight what's your
what's your solution what's your
suggestion for the demographic that's
the demographic we all come from here at
this table I I if I had the solution I
would be in Iowa New Hampshire I don't I
don't have solution
um I I I I don't know if I had the
solution I would have done something
about it there's no easy way out of it
no easy way out and I don't think
anybody has an easy way out
that's gonna be tough I mean but you
don't have a choice but have a side
hustle I mean you have to make it so
income's not going to make it thank you
for inviting me this has been a blast
thank you for coming out my pleasure
what we're going to do is Rob uh let's
put the link below folks if you watch
this highly recommend you go buy the
book how to invest we'll put in the chat
we'll put in the description get the
book it's one of the books I recommend
you read during this holiday season take
care everybody bye bye bye
okay